ranking men by attractiveness
we saw the girl version now it's time
for the boys
dear beauty all right let's skip the
interim
six bros versus one secret pewdiepie
that's kind of fudge
[Music]
we reached out to pewdiepie
and this is what happened let's go
we brought together six pewdiepie fans
also known as bros
i am a bro i am a bro i am a bro
i am a bro i am a bro i am a bro and
one secret pewdiepie i am
if the group discovers who pewdiepie is
they'll win a cash prize
if pewdiepie survives he wins the cash
prize
with cameras and mics off can the bros
vote out the real pewdiepie
this is odd man out
i i don't have a plan
i'm screwed my game plan is to just
honestly
look for what the most stereotypical
pewdiepie fan would be
okay my fake name is alex i'm 24.
i am from croydon in uk i watched
pewdiepie
since i was 16. i watch his amnesia
let's plays
that's usually what i hear people say
whenever they're send me a message
they're like i watch you since i was
blah blah blah and i was
amnesia i honestly the kids might get
voted out of the first child i'm not
gonna lie
we're gonna get pewdiepie let's be
honest here i know he's a bad liar
maybe that clip will be used against me
the wolves will need to work as a team
if they're to make a kill it's like a
weird game of among us we'll see how
this goes
yo greetings everyone hey guys i'm
brendan
the only thing alex has said so far i
was a little suspicious of this is
crazy one of these six people is
pewdiepie okay where's the gun
emoji that's not vegan no room i meant
to say from
that's so dumb if you're pewdiepie name
every video he made
if you're pewdiepie named every video
he's made
we got the states india we got vegas i'm
from london
i'm in texas
alex says he's from london london alex
is looking suspicious
i'm sort of timmy by the way because
pewter's always like a little timmy
whenever
it's true he does come on little timmy
was that your name
true that is his go-to
he's not very creative is that too much
of a giveaway
alex because this is gonna be so mean he
looks
like fat view
good point but i'm thinking alice
because he looks like fat fat pewdiepie
brendan going out alex jeez
he's got a point london voice us i'll
happily be fat pewdiepie
okay they're not dead on uh help me get
over
a breakup in 2017. oh friend babe
okay i trust brendan that's so nice
uh what do i respond today brandon seems
legit to be
so
[Music]
how do you do fellow kids uh i don't
know if it's timmy because like
i don't think pewds would say
i'm 90 sure it's alex hey bro fist of
the chat
i'll give you brofist alex as i vote you
out
[Music]
let's go oh my god i'm a little bit
nervous now i don't know like
everyone seems legit it's so weird being
in a jubilee video
they always seems like they had so much
time it went by like that
when i called alex out and i called him
fat pewdiepie which alex if you're not
pewdiepie i'm so sorry
the last thing kp said was cassidy suss
to me
so cassidy you're out i think i'll vote
for cassidy because
that's the only thing of suspicion i
really have i am gonna
vote off nikki because i had a bad
feeling about her right off the start
right now i'm kind of suspicious of alex
honestly the lmao and him saying yo
i'm gonna vote alex i'm gonna vote off
alex because i think other people are
voting alex
i don't know why pewdiepie would say
that he was from london because i would
immediately like
i don't know i'm gonna vote for alex i'm
gonna vote for alex
the votes are in for round one and the
person
eliminated this round is
[Laughter]
alex
[Music]
maybe picking london was too obvious i
should have gone to la or something
well done bros well done
he right out the gate i'm just curious
how the rest of this is going to get
played out now
what youtubers do you watch other than
pewds there should be none
cassidy i'm low-key sauce of you why
didn't they vote on cassidy then
cassidy's 22 female missouri no way
pewdiepie has any idea what missouri is
tyler likes the jubilee video i like the
mc minecraft series
my favorite series is three free games
bring it back i
never heard anyone say that is everyone
here
american spell color
what a good question nikki that's a
great question
oh i think cassidy is safe i think pewds
spell color like the european way are
any of you in the pewdiepie discord
not generally i just talked to friends
on there they're not on my discord what
is this
cassette is a mod there and created the
banner for the profit for the survey you
should join the server
or are you the admin
cassidy i think cassidy is safe
i like how they're all just vibing
they're like yeah whatever we got them
they went from cassidy to nikki
nikki going down hard on me but i get it
nikki counter with the most
strong argument you can make it's not me
that's really the only thing i've said
in the group chat this whole round is i
think we're not pewds i think we're not
pewds
that's enough for me i guess it's not
cassidy
cassidy says i know it ain't timmy
because peters doesn't have an iphone
these guys are playing 40 chests over
here i don't even know you could see if
you had an iphone
i based my entire strategy in round one
it was
alex and we had to get him out and now
that he's out i have no idea what to do
i'm probably still gonna go with brendan
because he really didn't put a lot of
input
in this round so nikki i'm sorry but
i think you're gonna have to go gosh i
guess i'm gonna go nikki
i think it's cassidy cassidy i think i'm
gonna vote for brendan this round
uh i'm most serious of tyler round two
elimination
the votes are in and we have a tie no
oh we have a tie the tie is between
nikki
and brendan brendan oh man
nikki and brendan that means we're going
to
tie breaker each person will get to
state one reason
saying why they like pewdiepie this is a
nice eco boost
all right so pewdiepie is the perfect
mix of not taking yourself too seriously
while still knowing how to tackle life
with self-respect that's why i really
like them
brendan get random money
i hope that that because that's actually
true growing up girls couldn't play
games in my house so watching p.s was
the only way i could participate in
gaming moment
oh what nicky you're gonna vote me
that's a really really good reason girls
can be gamers
everyone knows this keep gaming nikki i
think brendan is toast
oh no i don't feel like any of them are
pewds maybe he's doing big brain strats
and actually going for like a different
gender in a different race
the votes are in for the tiebreaker and
the person eliminated this round
is nikki
they wrote a nicky out way after that
sweet answer how could you that means
brendan's out you're done
you're done brendan how dare you call me
fat pewdiepie huh
what
okay brendan says i'm shocked you guys
didn't vote me nikki gave such a good
answer that was rafal sorry nikki
the baby car can i bash you because your
personal experience has helped you
yeah definitely i found pewds when i was
going through a breakup since he's
made since then he's made me laugh and
think differently almost on a weekly
basis
brendan give brendan money come on
they think that's us
[Music]
i'm from ohio that's where i'm from
you know the first video you watched of
his man that's a great question
either it was alex or pewds is doing
really well which i doubt no offense
alex
wow i feel like it could be tyler
because i feel like pewds would say
eleanor a lot not gonna lie
he's right i would say that a lot
they're getting into
nitty gritty now i specifically remember
being at like a dance duty when i was
like
seven and seeing appears to be back when
he had duck profile
picture all right that's specific tyler
sticking to the story tyler
only 14. i think it's tyler got him out
i don't know i have no idea i have no
clue
it's funny seeing them interact it feels
like i'm not supposed to see this almost
i really guess kp i that's really all i
can think of
i think i might go with brad because the
breakup thing
i mean you could definitely make that up
i think i'm gonna vote for brendan i
gotta vote for tyler
it's gotta be tyler i don't think
pewdiepie would try to pretend he was a
young kid that would be kind of weird
i still think it's brandon the votes are
in for round three
and the person eliminated this round is
please
brendan i knew it oh my god
i knew it was coming i should have been
a little bit more
personable in the chat if everyone feels
confident that you already voted out
pewdiepie
you can end the game now if the majority
has doubt
the game will continue they're going to
end the game for sure
i think we got him i think we should
ever hear we're going to vote out one
more person
i think if we win another round i would
get eliminated majority has voted
no we will end the game oh my god
i'm sorry nikki i'm sorry brendan
if the color that shows up is green you
all win if it's red
pewdiepie is still in the game and you
all lost whatever happens i'm happy i
made it to the end
in three two one
well done
the game is over and the bros have won
now the moment of truth
let's find out who is pewdiepie please
turn on your cameras in three
two one
it's fat pewdiepie
[Music]
why do you do me like that man
it was the bitmoji because on the the
lmao was so stereotypical on the
headphones and the phone i didn't make
that big emoji
oh my god i can't believe
this is happening right now i genuinely
cannot believe this right now
i'm not surprised you guys got it to be
honest so well done to everyone
sorry there was a few casualties on the
way oh you had fun as well
last question for you pewdiepie if you
were to call out another celebrity or
influencer to be part of odd man out who
would it be
um mr beast
the one and only oh big money behind it
hey yo bro well done
my life is guys you guys were great i
was trying not to get emotional this
whole time
he is my favorite youtuber and he has
inspired me so
much man my biggest takeaway from this
experience is just that we have such a
great community
you know the nine-year-olds 19 year olds
whatever you want to call it the bro
army to be
humble i think i think that's one of
pewdiepie's most shining qualities
being a bro means family
brofist shout out to period seven please
include that editors
next week we're back with the new season
of
odd one out who is a makeup artist off
the top of your head that you like do
you look up to
vino manny
oh my god messed up can i do that again
it's not the second book
yes it is yeah she does it twice she
does it in the first one and the second
one yeah this actress well she's drama
club
oh yeah that's true next to you
mommy to tell you something and she's
like what and i'm like i like girls
what do you guys do i'm a makeup artist
i am a cheerleader i'm a high schooler
i'm bisexual i'm
a harry potter fan stay tuned for odd
one out
[Music]
you